[Music]
snack food is often deemed as unhealthy
but
it doesn't have to be registered
dietitian mia sin
shares tips on how to snack smarter
without breaking your diet plus
some delicious recipes that you can make
at home
hey las vegas now i hope you like
snacking because today i have some
delicious healthier options
plus some tips on how to snack smarter
so my first tip
is to focus on protein and fiber which
will help you feel full
longer american pecans are the original
super nut that can elevate the nutrition
of your snacks without sacrificing
cravable taste
and satisfying crunch each one ounce
serving of pecans provides three grams
of protein and fiber
along with essential minerals including
zinc and 12 grams of good
monounsaturated fats they're among the
lowest in carbs and highest in fiber
compared to other nuts
whether you want something sweet savory
crunchy or creamy
pecans are incredibly versatile and can
enhance any snack break
use them to make these savory spiced
pecan energy bites
for the batter blend together a half cup
of pecan pieces one cup of oats two
tablespoons of tahini one tablespoon of
honey a half tablespoon of mustard and
your savory spices
find these recipes and more delicious
and nutritious ways to clean up your
snacks with pecans
at americanpecan.com snacks
now bars are another way to check your
protein and fiber boxes
iq bars are protein bars formulated with
ingredients and nutrients
shown to benefit the brain including
lion's mane and mct
they have 12 grams of plant protein and
are vegan keto friendly and free of
gluten and dairy
find them at smith's sprouts cvs and eat
iqbar.com
next find nutritious ways to satisfy
your sweet cravings
try apple cookies slice your apples into
fourth inch thick rounds
i'm using the cosmic crisp apples which
are grown in washington state and prized
for their perfectly balanced flavor and
delightfully crisp
texture they're a cross between
enterprise and honey crisp apples
they're great for baking
and snacking another better way to
satisfy your sweet cravings is with
fruit popsicles
popsicle fruit twisters are a fun better
for your treat with 70 calories per pop
made with real fruit
milk and no artificial flavors they come
in delicious varieties including
strawberry blueberry and vanilla swirl
and the new mango strawberry and vanilla
swirl finally find nutritious ways to
satisfy your crunchy craving
these bite-sized organic rice cake minis
by lundberg family farms
fit the bill they're made with organic
whole grain brown rice and come in sweet
and savory flavors including white
cheddar
sea salt apple pie and buffalo ranch my
favorite is the ginger seaweed which are
tossed in a savory umami seasoning with
a kick of heat and a dab of sweet for a
super unique flavor
i recommend pairing this crunchy whole
grain snack with nutritious dips like
guacamole salsa or hummus
to build a satisfying snack now we hope
you enjoyed all of these tips and
recipes you can find them at my website
nutritionbymia.com
and nutritionbynia on instagram where i
also share meal ideas and nutrition tips
daily thank you mia las vegas now will
be